it's incredible what's happened to you
not that it's not deserved but your
career took this direction which
no one foresaw which is now you're a
a helicopter pilot in army of the dead
zack snyder's new offering yes and
it's this whole new you that none of us
saw coming i have here
this is i think the cover of metro
weekly
um i don't know if that's oh here it is
oh thank you very much a
burglar just handed me this this is you
on the cover
of metro weekly ticket tarot action
hero yeah that's incredible yeah it's
it's um didn't see that coming yeah and
then it says up here
scary good road head right we saw that
coming
um this is i mean you're an action star
now and you look the part you look cool
i know um well not i know i look cool
but i mean
i do kind of know you do look cool yeah
i mean i have to say when they gave me
that outfit
and i was doing my uh wardrobe changes
at home
yeah i walked out of and it was all in
my backyard i walked out into the
backyard kind of
like i think this is
how i'm supposed to be dressed like it
felt so right
i thought when they handed to me i was
like oh okay how funny
it's so crazy you were meant to be an
action star um
well i i i i've done
a little bit of action on star trek i
mean i'm mainly just in sarcastic
tig in space right um and then i mace
mainly just sarcastic tig and helicopter
running from
from zombies uh it's a big deal working
with
uh with zack snyder yeah and i'm told
you have a clip
uh this they're very secretive about the
project but this is a clip that you're
allowed to show is that right
yeah uh well there's been um
you know the movie it did really well i
think it's netflix's
biggest movie it's huge yeah that
they've ever put out
and um their sequels and um prequels and
everything uh
in the works and animated series and
i've been asked if i'm a part of any of
that
and i have a very exciting
uh i have something very exciting to
share and it's that i am
in a um in a sequel you're in a sequel
yeah all right i understand this is
strategy it's a prequel or sequel i
actually
don't know well it depends does it take
place afterwards or before
i know the difference between them but
nobody told me if this is a prequel or a
sequel
can't help you but this is i have
not only a clip from it but i have the
entire movie
you're gonna show the entire movie right
now yeah let's take a look
yeah wow i didn't see that ending coming
that's fantastic
at the beginning yeah but that middle
part
huh so that cost 600 million dollars to
make that's right
um that's actually a digital did you
know that wasn't really me
could you tell i couldn't really tell
could you tell that wasn't
you play it again but it's a digital
recreation of your creation of my whole
body
and zach made i think your ride's here
pig
this it's a ridiculous place to shoot a
show
it says there's a clown car out front
trying to get our attention
nice yeah that's one of my uh famous
that's one of your impressions
yeah there's a truck
there's a truck backing up in the alley
and there's a car out front
leaning on the horn a clown out back
i could just interrupt my own interview
and just while you're talking here let's
do it ask me a question
anyway
[Music]
we don't need this circuit i don't need
these idiots around this theater
[Laughter]
[Music]
army of the dead i'm gonna keep going
army of the dead is available now on
netflix
and uh takes podcasts don't ask tig and
take and cheryl true story
are both available wherever you get your
podcasts
and i'm going to be on uh don't ask tig
yes but tig and cheryl
is the podcast i do with cheryl hines
curb your enthusiasm she's hilarious
she is incredible we talk about we very
loosely talk about a new documentary
every week
and i mean very loosely very loosely
meaning you haven't probably seen it
uh love talking to you and uh we our
paths will cross again soon i do promise
you
okay well your office is down the street
from my house yes it is and i see you
all the time take notaro
take a break we'll be right back
you